[Music]
how it's gonna work is you're gonna say
if you're this step forward hello
beautiful people okay so you all have
something in common
every single one of you you're all
different so it's gotta be something on
the inside I grew up in North Brunswick
New Jersey our claim to fame is that
John Bongiovi got kicked out of our high
school my horoscope sign has areas I
don't think it has any significance in
my life my childhood was interesting
mostly you know outdoors growing up on
an island off of the coast so it was
very different
Oh Oh step forward if you have asthma I
had no idea you guys got that back step
forward if you are vegetarian
no okay step forward if you're comedian
everybody though I currently go to
school whole time I'm also a transient
recording artist being a resident nature
I love sports I love comedy I have a cat
one cat named sativa I'll let you guess
why I call her that I mean it's it's
2018 it's it's legal say step forward if
you smoked weed
we'll all talk later guys but the three
said that's reset that faux-wood if your
Fingal Wow okay step forward if you
think elf is the best movie ever made
Hollywood so step forward if you've been
on TV everybody close yeah forward if
you're anemic its step forward if you
have had any sort of cancer before damn
I don't think I'm good I don't think I'm
gonna get it it feels like a tingling
like pins and needles when you're like
fingers go numb are you laid on your arm
too long it feels like that but in my
chest I think I hide it pretty well but
it definitely affects my life not so
much anymore I I think I have it under
control now step forward if you're an
only child oh wow make sense when I do
tell people it just kind of catches them
off guard because what I do for work
they see me as like an actual vert it's
like there's a creature picking at you
all the time this is actually something
that people deal with from day to day
but the fear of of being open about this
they keep it a secret
yeah I give up I got I give up I don't
know what this is about step forward if
you have anxiety freaking never really
congratulations guys you're worried I'm
kidding I have it too I was diagnosed
with generalized anxiety disorder which
is just an easy way to say we're not
sure you just feel bad all the time my
diagnosis is general anxiety disorder my
anxiety is a little bit different maybe
than your average generalized anxiety
because I actually got diagnosed with
PTSD several years ago after an
incidence of sexual assault they did
diagnose me with anxiety a little bit of
social anxiety
and depression I'm diagnosed with
general anxiety disorder I've struggled
with anxiety for pretty much all of my
life I thought it was depression and
it's a bit of depression but it's mostly
I have high anxiety people around me are
always surprised that I have anxiety
because I grew up in a hair salon so I
was constantly around people I grew up
kind of as an only child I've been away
I love attention I'm always willing to
perform but I have a time limit you know
it's not something that I talk about
publicly
all the time people probably don't see
the stress and the anxiety and the panic
that is often you know right below the
surface that's really brave you guys
share on a BuzzFeed platform you look
beautiful
good love and good energy you know if
you guys doesn't matter it doesn't
matter where you're from or what you do
or who you like anyone could have
anxiety I feel like my life would be
easier in a lot of ways if I didn't have
to live with it
but I also feel like everything that's a
part of you makes you who you are I
think that we should begin to create a
safe space to normalize things like this
so that people won't feel so ashamed of
getting treatment and getting help
[Music]